to the woods we are broadcasting live
from Finnish Nature Center haltia
dear prime minister dear president of
the European commission the prime
minister's dear commissioner and their
ministers and Their audience welcome
on this early and chilly Winter's day
and morning we will actually be
continuing from where the climate cop
last weekend left under Egypt's hot sun
that is how can we prevent a dangerous
climate disaster how can we mitigate
greenhouse gas emissions
today we will have a specific Focus
that is the topic and the role of
forests Wood Construction and
architecture and the common framework
for this approach is of course the new
European Bauhaus the cultural initiative
and inspiration that's been the topic in
the architectural and the design circles
for a couple of years already now
my name is I come from the ministry of
the environment of Finland and I will be
moderating the event today and I am the
coordinator of the Nordic Bell House
program here in Finland
uh today we will first have a high level
event in the beginning which will take
about two hours then there will be a
break and then thereafter we will go
into
separate panel discussions and end the
day uh in a summary and networking event
and uh there's also a possibility for
for discussions today online and I will
get back to that a bit later
but now let's start the event with our
first speaker
it's a great pleasure to welcome the
prime minister of Finland Sana Marie
prime minister please welcome to the
wuss
thank you so much dear friends president
of the commission dear Ursula prime
minister Carlos the arcaya Deputy Prime
Minister EBA Bush dear participants
you're mostly welcome into the woods to
the Phoenix Nature Center haltia and
this conference
today is all about focusing our minds on
forests food-based materials and
sustainability
the built environment is a key position
in our work to achieve carbon neutrality
it generates one-third of all emissions
both in Finland and globally
according to the ipcc we should cut
these emissions by 80 percent by 3050.
this is a big challenge
however there are several ways to reduce
emissions from the built environment
we have already taken many steps when it
comes to Energy Efficiency next we need
to take steps towards material
efficiency
on our current part the production of
cement still Elaine aluminum and
Plastics is to set generate almost twice
the amount of emissions we can allow by
2050 if we want to limit global warming
in 1.5 degrees
that is why we must also find
alternatives to emission intensive
materials in the construction sector
as we all know wood and bio-based
materials can offer great opportunities
for decarbonizing our building stock
we need to move towards agreeing by
economy in all sectors and cons and
construction is no exception
that said we must maintain a careful
balance in our forests we must not
Harvest too much we must not sacrifice
biodiversity and we must take good care
of forest ecosystems so that these
carbon sinks can continue to play their
vital role in our carbon neutrality
goals
they're not the same for carbon
neutrality by 2035
to ensure this we have invited different
sectors in our society to develop their
own roadmaps towards these goals
we expect every sector to bring its
Solutions and commitments to the joint
effort
in our government we have also turned
attention to the climate impact of the
built environment
we have speed up the development of
policy on climate declaration for
buildings if you want to steer the
climate impact of the built environment
we first need to know what they are we
cannot manage something we cannot
measure
with construction plays essential role
in decarbonizing our construction sector
the government has boot construction
program that supports the construction
sector in finding new ways of building
with wood
this program has done remarkable work to
promote low carbon Solutions and
strengthen International collaboration
in these fields
buildings are also important for the
economy and our well-being around 80
percent of our national wealth is in the
built environment and we spent over 90
percent of our time indoors
we must solve the environmental
challenges of construction while
maintaining its role in the economy and
ensuring healthy and comfortable
conditions in buildings
we also have the balance different aims
when regulating the use of forests
it is clear that first policy as such
belongs to the EU member states
at the same time the EU climate
environment and energy policies have
diver Direct effects on Forest and
Forestry
when we set goals at the EU or Global
lever level that have an impact on
forests we should remember that forests
and conditions are different in
different countries and in different
parts of Europe
we should also bear in mind that 60 of
forests in Finland are owned by private
citizens
Finland is committed that the goals we
set together in the EU or Global level
but it should be left to decision makers
at the national and local level defined
and use the best possible methods for
implementation
another key element related to the
future use of forests is predictability
this is especially important when we
discuss multiple proposals affecting the
use of forests
a constant source of renewable material
at the same time Forest owners and the
forest industry plan to execute their
Investments over a time frame of decades
as such we must avoid constantly
reviewing and changing the regulations
that affect them
this would weaken Europe's Global
position as a place for in in a
Innovative industry that develops
sustainable ways of production
complex complex problems require new
Solutions
we need to create
we need creativity and Innovation we
need to bring in Creative potential of
architecture and design and we need
cross-disciplinary collaboration and new
skills
in this context another issue we should
pay attention is the impact of climate
change and environmental challenges of
our well-being
young people in particular are
legitimately concerned about the state
of our planet
we know that level of environmental
anxiety and depression are increasing
we need to act on these challenges
arts and culture can offer channels for
addressing this
spending time in the forest can Inspire
design and architecture but also
promotes mental and physical well-being
sustainable architecture can help us
develop better solutions for the global
crisis we are facing
all of this is embodied in the new
European Bauhaus initiative
which Finland is actively participating
with our Nordic Neighbors
today's event is a prime example of this
collaboration
I want to thank you dear Ursula for this
initiative and I'm glad to announce our
participation with the development of
digital learning materials for food Wood
Construction
today we will discuss the role of
forests construction and architecture
from the Viewpoint of building a
corporate neutral Europe I I encourage
you to take a Visionary View and imagine
the solutions for tomorrow
I'm convinced that together we can make
them a reality thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you very much prime minister Santa
Marin our next speaker has actually
initiated the entire new European
Bauhaus movement
she's none less than Ursula of Wonder
lion the president of the European
commission president it's a great honor
to invite you to the podium please
[Applause]
foreign
Deputy Prime Minister EBA bush
distinguished guests and dear friends
it's a pleasure to be here with you
indeed we are a relatively short drive
from Helsinki and we are in the heart of
nature
and I could not think of a better place
than this one to discuss the importance
of forests
we are learning more every day about the
immense role
these rich and complex ecologic systems
play for the health of people but of
course also for the health of our planet
Europe's 400 billion trees absorb almost
nine percent of our continent's
greenhouse gas emissions
for example by retaining water they help
to prevent floods and drugs
and they are even stabilizing rainfall
patterns by shaping the clouds we see in
the sky
so far it's our livelihoods they are
energy
building materials and of course
they are economic growth and many many
important jobs
new Innovative products are being
developed wood-based products have an
enormous potential to replace fossil
based products
and I'm very much looking forward to
learn more about all this today at this
conference so let's have a look at the
forests
for thousands of years forests have been
for us an enchanted place of mystery and
Magic as well as modern science
in our oldest fairy tales and folk tales
forests are the home and you know it all
of spirits of wise animals of wizards of
Healers
today more than 25 percent of our
medicines still originate in rainforest
Forest Planet rainforest plants
forests are in the widest sense of the
word part of Who We Are
and they must be our shared
responsibility
because we all know that today our
forests globally are in danger
near my home town in Hanover that's the
northern part of Germany there is a
forest that I have known since decades
and whenever I come home I take a walk
in this Forest
and in the recent years I've seen this
Forest withering
pests are thriving
in our warming climate you know all the
signs of this development
also here in the North
forests are changing with the climate
this summer wildfires in the European
Union released an amount of carbon
that is equivalent to the annual
emission of around 5 million cars annual
emission
we know that scientists are debating
whether forests in Europe are carbon
sinks or rather net carbon emitters
whatever the outcome of this debate is
there's certainly one point we can all
agree on
healthy forests
are our strongest allies
to fight for a healthy planet
and we need to do more to save and
better manage our forests and this is
what brings us here today to this
conference
let me begin with the global picture
in the last three decades
an area that is larger than the whole
European Union has been lost to
deforestation
and we all have a responsibility in this
consumption in the European Union for
example is said to be responsible for
about 10 percent of these losses
but now with the European green deal we
have to decided not only to address the
problem
but to be part of the solution
a regulation on deforestation free
products for example is said to be
adopted next month just in time before
the cup 15 in Montreal our message is
very clear
Europe is cleaning up its Supply chains
for products that trigger deforestation
and this marks a turning point in the
global fight against deforestation
because the regulation addresses not
only the illegal deforestation
but all forms of deforestations that
cuts down trees
without replanting them
soon only products that are not based on
deforestation will be allowed to our
single Market
but we also know
that the solution can not only be a
simple ban
because forests are an important
economic and also cultural Factor so we
need to give an alternative to
deforestation to those local communities
who depend so much on forests for their
livelihoods
like for example creating new jobs
sharing know-how in conservation of
forests
supporting new Supply chains for
sustainably
sourced Timber
last year in Glasgow I signed for the
European Union a 1 billion Euro Global
Forest pledge that was the Pledge and
this year
at cop27 in charmele Sheikh I could sign
five forest Port Partnerships with five
different countries to put this pledge
in action and it's exactly what we are
working on to make sure that there's an
alternative to deforestation for these
communities
just to give you an example for example
would processing in guayana or Forest
Products like honey in Uganda or
sustainable tourism in the Republic of
Congo so not only ban the deforestation
or fight the deforestation but really
create viable alternatives
the local communities can thus make a
living
by protecting and by respecting their
forests
this is how we address the global
challenge of deforestation through
closer cooperation and giving people a
sustainable alternative that is good for
them and good for the planet
now here in Europe we have Decades of
experience in sustainable Forestry
for example you here in Finland
Forest resource data has been regularly
collected since the 1920s already
so with this knowledge together we can
build on your experience
and take it to the next level
and this is my second Point let us join
forces to nurture how far is
biodiversity and bio economy
let us shift the incentives
from short-lived uses of Natural
Resources
to long-lived and circular ones
and this is the aim of the European land
use revision
the final Missing Link is a proposal for
certification of carbon removal
it is a quality guarantee
to people and organizations who want to
fund carbon removal activities
so not only can we then better monitor
that our forests remain carbon sinks
but Foresters and Forest owners
will be recognized and rewarded for the
time and the care they invest to keep
our forests healthy and as you said Sana
I think it was 60 of the forest here in
Finland is owned
by private people so let's reward them
for the the care they are giving and the
nurturing they are providing to their
forests
these measures help ensure that Timber
is sustainably harvested not just in
your countries here but also across the
European Union
so this covers the supply side of the
equation
on the demand side we need to do more to
promote the use of long-lived
biomaterials like quality wood for
construction
and this is indeed where the new
European Bauhaus comes into play
we want to improve people's lives by
designing and building sustainably
and to see what I mean I mean you just
have to look around into this building
The Finnish Nature Center
a cross-laminated Timber building we're
in here
when it was built in 2013 it was the
first of its kind in northern Europe
today if you look at the overall
material input in the European
construction Timber is three percent so
I would say it's still a niche but with
a big room for improvement and the
demand is growing fast
and the new European Bauhaus wants to
drive this transformation
you might know that the original Bauhaus
movement that was founded in 1919
explored specifically new construction
methods and new materials at that time
it was of course concrete and steel
but at that time already there was a
great Finnish architect known around the
world his name is Alvar Alto
very famous he was a Pioneer at that
time already because he loved to work
with wood he used wood and created icons
of wooden furniture actually if you look
at them today they are still extremely
modern in their design so outstanding
now today we are lucky
because we have a whole generation
of young Architects designers Engineers
that want to redefine our way of
building and living
and they are rediscovering natural
materials such as Timber
and they have understood how smart
nature is to find Solutions and they try
to understand these nature-based
Solutions and to transform them into our
world of construction for example
we all know that today building with
Timber could save
up to 40 percent of carbon emissions in
comparison to concrete that's a huge
figure
so by keeping the carbon inside the wood
one day Timber could turn our homes and
even entire cities
into carbon sinks
to some of you this might sound like a
dream
but in Finland
as well as in Estonia and Sweden you are
showing Europe already
how this works how this is possible and
doable
you have centuries of experience in
building out of wood
and we need your experience
now more than ever to encourage
sustainable forestry and lead the next
revolution in architecture
so the new European Bauhaus aims to be a
movement that brings like-minded people
together
to generate new collaborations and new
ideas
and bring to a wider public than many
many wonderful things that are being
done by Pioneers like you
and this brings me to my third and final
point
let's Empower people
to lead and drive this change
the growing importance that forests and
construction will play in the green
transition
requires new skills or perhaps it's old
skills rediscovered
so we need more Rangers Engineers
chemists chemists Time Timber Craftsmen
data specialist you name it
and we know that these skills are in too
short supply today
there's a recent report by the E4
Institute that found that nearly 35
percent
of EU construction firms
report a shortage of skilled workers 35
percent
so Skilling has to grow with the
transformation we are aiming at there
will not be a green transformation if we
don't have the skills and if they are
not people who drive the transformation
and that is why we have proposed to make
the year 2023 the European year of
skills
the idea is to better match the
different Skilling strategy with the
economy's needs for specific skills in
the labor market
it is about bringing industry Forest
owners trade unions universities
training providers together
an approach that we are pioneering with
our pact of four skills
we have created 12 large-scale
Partnerships
offering Skilling opportunities to 6
million European citizens of working age
but we need much much more than this
and this is why I am happy to announce
today that we are launching a new
European Bauhaus Academy
the academy will have three major
priorities
first of all
it is about fostering green and digital
skills in construction
we want to reskill and upskill at least
three million construction workers in
the next five years because we need them
now to drive the transformation
the second point is we need more
research and development and innovation
in this crucial crucial sector and for
that we need increased funding
therefore Horizon Europe you all know
our research program highly worldwide
renowned
will soon make a call for nature-based
material demonstrators worth 10 million
euros we want to know what's out there
as innovative ideas to the end
development and bring them to the market
I'm very grateful to John schellenhuber
for his initiative and advice in this
issue
and we also want to learn from the new
European Bauhaus
how regulation can incentivize
the use of quality Nature by Solutions
and biomaterials
and finally the new Academy will have a
very strong digital Focus
we want to provide online courses for
sustainable forestry design and Wood
Construction
and thus basically create a truly
European wood Academy of Forest Academy
and we will do that together with you
the Nordic Bauhaus many many thanks for
joining this the commission will make
available an additional 1 million euros
I want to thank all three of you for
your enormous commitment it is your
network
of universities of Architects of urban
pla planners of construction companies
you are the leaders in the field of
sustainability and we need your
knowledge and we need your network to
bring the best together
I think we can multiply your experience
and your Innovations all across the
European Union and across the world
because we are perhaps one small part of
a global ecosystem but we can be a big
part of the solution if we do it right
so ladies and gentlemen
you all know the old saying when people
sometimes miss the obvious
we say you lose sight of the forest for
the trees
well here today we do the exact opposite
we're zooming out and it's about the big
picture that we want to discuss it's
about embracing the importance of
forests for our lives and our
livelihoods
it's about forests as our home
for us as our economic foundation and of
course Forest as our best allies to
fight climate change many things
thank you
thank you very much president for the
line very inspiring words and a new
European battle House Academy how about
that that sounds very exciting as well
now it's about the time to hear from our
neighbors because as you all know and
have heard here in the north the climate
is unfortunately warming faster than in
the rest of the planet so we are heading
towards a greater degree warming already
by now than the rest of the places and
that's of course a concern to our
forests
and therefore we are collaborating and
trying to find ways with our neighboring
countries of what to do with this and
therefore it's more than appropriate now
to hear their views it's a great
pleasure first to invite to the stage
prime minister of Estonia Carlos please
[Applause]
dear friends
it is my great pleasure to be here today
and I'm very thankful for our Finnish
hosts who have this conference and
making this event happen
and literally bringing us into the woods
and also um thank you Ursula for the new
um European Bauhaus we have a saying
just like you said in Estonian as well
you need to see the forest behind the
trees which means that we have to zoom
out this is what the new European
Bauhaus is all about
every Estonian is passionate about
forests because a forest is more than we
can measure
it has been an important place to hide
due to highest history to find peace and
embrace nature and it also is as as we
said it's a poor man's fur coat
as Forest rich countries forests have a
special role in our culture and our
people's hearts and although estonians
are known as very tech savvy people we
are actually very forest-minded people
as well every child in Estonia knows
which berries and and mushrooms you can
eat in the forest and there's also a
joke that you can eat all the mushrooms
just so some of them only once
forests are pivotal to the green
transition and a part of the solutions
in reaching climate neutrality
just like all the other sectors
we have set the much needed climate and
biodiversity goals in the EU in order to
fight global climate change
but these goals and Ambitions are only
doable if we consider the right role for
each sector and solutions for their
transition
we expect a lot from our forests but
their main role is in is absorbing
carbon and it is also important
Sanctuary for many species and habitats
or it is also a vital source of
livelihood and provider of resources
but it's also a place where we like to
spend our time to hike exercise relieve
stress
as the founder of Bauhaus School Walter
gopis has said under trees the urban
dweller might restore his troubled mind
and find the blessing of a creative pose
as one can see finding a balance between
these sometimes conflicting roles of
preservation and use is challenging
as another Estonian proverb says there
is no Forest behind the forest
can be cut only once in a lifetime we
should aim to make it profitable for the
owner as well as for the nature
increasing natural zinc and biodiversity
are vital if we are if we are to achieve
climate neutrality
only this way we can ensure our forests
can fulfill all their functions also in
50 and 100 years time
as Forest rich countries with long
experience in sustainable Forest
management Estonia Finland and Sweden
can be Pioneers in transforming the
sector to be future proof
perhaps as a way forward a forestry also
needs its own just transition fund for
certain parts of the sector we should
also make preserving forests profitable
for the owner not only logging
today we are discussing how we use the
resources that we get from the forest I
believe that this is one of the most
important questions regarding any
material we use
while sustainable biomass surely has its
role in the energy sector transition in
short term The Way Forward should be
through using wood for long-term and
high value products
and perhaps this is also the way to
bring these
restoring and blessing effects Walter
cropius was talking about closer to more
urban dwellers
high value use cases such as wood as
construction material are much more
noticeable to people this means that
they see the changes the green
transition in
is bringing to our lives
and if we do it right we can inspire
people by showing the Improvement it
brings to their living spaces
this is what the new Powerhouse
initiative is all about
Timber is a natural fit for the European
Bauhaus initiative and the initiative
itself can be important enabler of
sustainable Forest Management in the
long term
we have used wood as construction
material since prehistoric times and our
histories are deeply intertwined with it
Estonian children still visit the old
wooden farmhouses that their forefathers
lived in they use timber to build their
own first tree houses
and of course when we are building a
sauna we built it out of wood
this is the Deep connection with our
material within our societies
in the last 30 years the technology of
using Timber as a building material has
developed a lot and we have means to
connect the old and the modern
to bring sustainable wood used to modern
architecture and City Planning we have
seen this development in Estonia already
first hand new schools kindergartens
apartment buildings and much more are
being built using timber in a
contemporary way
this is why I'm proud that this event
has been the impulse to create platform
between Estonia Finland and Sweden to
develop skills related to the use of
wood in the new European Bauhaus
this will also be our contribution to
the new European bauhus Academy that
Ursula was talking about
we want to develop skills related to the
sustainable use of wood
and provide opportunities for our
scientists and companies to work
together
beads are strong wooden houses sector
whose products have reached over 70
countries or the newly opened Timber
architecture Research Center at the
Estonian ectomy of Arts we need people
who are able to understand the vision of
the new European Powerhouse and the
opportunities and challenges
that sustainable Wood Construction
brings
I'm also very happy to announce that
Estonia will be joining the Nordic
Bauhaus family this will be an excellent
opportunity for our scientists and
companies to develop shared culture and
vision in building the best living
environment and connect people with
nature I wish you all a fruitful
discussions and very good event thank
you
[Applause]
thank you very much prime minister
Carlos and warmly welcome to the Nordic
Bell house next let's go over to Sweden
and it's a great pleasure to invite
deputy prime minister Ed babush please
[Applause]
thank you so much dear excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
I'm deeply honored to be here
representing the new Swedish government
and I would like to thank our Finnish
colleagues for inviting us all and for
arranging this event in this beautiful
beautiful Venice
as nordners we are all somehow related
to the forest
the woods are our home environment and
at the same time one of our most
important resources
it is a key resource for our industry as
well as for our well-being culture and
environment
using wood for building our houses has
been a matter of course for as long as
we have lived here
among swedes the small the small red
painted wood houses is probably one of
the foremost National symbols that we
all can relate to
I reckon most of you here are also
familiar with the works of Swedish
author astrilingrian
and those bullaby houses are common on
this side of the Baltic Sea as well
now might be the time for us to broaden
the scope for what the woods can bring
us
it might also be part of the solutions
for the great challenges that we face
today
climate change leaves no one unaffected
environmental problems are one of the
great cross-border issues of our time
our climate and environment policy must
be ambitious
the Swedish government will develop a
program for international climate
investments in accordance with article 6
of the Paris agreement
these investments will contribute to
achieving the Swedish climate objective
of net zero emissions by 2045.
when it comes to climate action
yeah trade-offs must be made when
interests are at odds forestry is one
example we would like to encourage the
EU to take full account of the role that
the forest plays both as a source of
energy as a base for sustainable
products and as an economic engine but
also as a carbon sink and basis for
biodiversity
forestry and the use of forest-based
products is really key a key priority
for the green transition
forest-based products such as wooden
houses both reduce the dependency of
fossil based materials and act as carbon
sinks often for Generations
therefore we need more not less
sustainably produced wood from the
forest we need the forest to grow even
better and continue to develop the way
we manage our forests High environmental
Ambitions should go hand in hand with
increased sustainable Forest growth and
production
each Forest
is a unique forest and each Forest owner
is unique with unique goals for her
Forest
this diversity is a valuable strength as
well as a big opportunity
in line with this I think it it is
crucial to um
to think that one size fits all is is
not the way forward when it comes to
forestry it is important to allow for
consideration to both local and Regional
conditions and it is my firm belief that
sustainable forestry contributes to both
fight climate change Safeguard
biological diversity and to enhance the
bioeconomy many Swedish business actors
have solutions that can accelerate the
transition in areas such as sustainable
materials renewable energy and Energy
Efficiency as well as create future
competitiveness and add values for
people and the society
modern industrialized construction with
wood is an excellent excellent example
of this in Sweden wood increases rapidly
as a building material in both family
houses schools and other buildings and
this creates double climate benefits
carbon stored in the buildings as well
as less CO2 emissions from fossil based
materials
around 70 percent of Sweden is forests
we have some humans as well but a lot is
Forest
and about 80 of our forests is in active
use for Timber production
every year almost 100 million cubic
meters is harvested to be used as
long-lived Wood Products packaging paper
and energy all over the world
and every year at least
380 million trees are planted in Sweden
380 million trees that's a lot
over the past 100 years Sweden's Forest
Resort has doubled active and
sustainable Forest management is an
important part of that
apart from the obvious climate benefits
of woods construction I would also like
to highlight other positive aspects of
this material because wood is unique in
the potential it brings to
industrialization given its low weight
you can manufacture quite large
prefabricated elements in a controlled
Factory environment and this enables
automation repetition and also cost
effectiveness
as the construction sector struggles
with low productivity low Innovation and
high costs the benefits of increasing
productivity in this sector cannot be
understated
what goes around comes around
Finn's phrase it
for months more
Sana you'll have to help me with my
finish afterwards you you you thank you
you've heard why why finishes the
official language in heaven right
it's because it takes an eternity to
learn
not my joke
on a serious note no one can deny that
the design of our built living
environments impacts our lives and and
also shapes us as human beings
it affects our performance resilience
health and well-being also and it it
also how it affects how we take part in
society
high quality in architecture and design
is therefore a matter of quality of life
and sustainability
the new European Bauhaus reflects
Sweden's view on architecture and design
as key tools for building sustainable
societies we all need carefully designed
living environments that are both
human-centered and address all the
dimensions of sustainability
the creative process of Architects and
designers offers unique opportunities to
probe more deeply into the problems and
conditions prevalent in our societies to
find new solutions to Spur innovation
process and the transition to Green
economy and not least to create
sustainable inclusive and beautiful
Living Spaces spaces and environments in
both urban and rural areas
with architectural expertise sustainable
forest-based materials and Innovative
companies the tradition of Wood
Construction can continue to create
resilient and beautiful living
environments for future Generations
from a Swedish perspective I really
really appreciate the ambition of this
event to highlight the value chain from
forest to build environment in line with
the Ambitions of the new European
Bauhaus this holistic view to
sustainable development might be a key
to Future progress
Innovation and research are long-term
Motors of economy increased investments
in these areas is crucial for European
companies to assert themselves in global
competition
the progress in Wood Building Technology
is a great example of how such
Investments can help us solve the Urgent
challenges over time
for the coming Generations
I thank you once again for bringing
these crucial issues to the agenda and I
wish you all a fruitful day of
discussions and cooperations thank you
so much
[Applause]